[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> UH, UH.
IT'S THAT NEW TRACK.
NEW MONEY CREW.
CASH STACK RECORDS.
REPRESENT.
♪♪♪
BIG CHRIS!
>> WITH SHANTASIA.
>> FEATURING YOUR BOY,
YUNG BITCH.
>> HERE IT COMES.
PRINSEXXXY ON THE TRACK
HOLDIN' IT DOWN ♪
>> SNO'CONE!
>> YEAH.
THEY UP ON THIS TRACK, TOO.
Y'ALL AIN'T NEVER HEARD THIS
MANY EMCEES.
YO, HERE WE GO.
YO.
>> SLOPPY MOSES ALSO PART OF
THIS.
BRINGING THAT WEST COAST STANK.
>> HIM TOO.
AND THAT'S MORE THAN ENOUGH NOW.
♪♪♪
YEAH.
>> BIG CHRIS.
>> SHANTASIA.
>> YUNG BITCH!
>> WITH PRINSEXXXY.
>> WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE.
>> SNO'CONE!
>> MARCI JAMZ.
>> AND SLOPPY MOSES.
♪ AND THEN WE CUT IT OFF
THERE, UH ♪
♪♪♪
>> I MEAN, WE MORE THAN COVERED
ON THIS PARTICULAR TRACK.
AND YO, DON'T THINK I AIN'T
NOTICE YOU TRYING TO FLY UNDER
THE RADAR, MARCI JAMZ!
I SEE YOU.
♪ I SEE NEW MONEY CREW
ROLLS DEEP ♪
>> I MEAN, MAYBE TOO DEEP?
I DON'T KNOW.
♪♪♪
FEATURING KING KEEF ♪
>> NO!
THIS TRACK IS FULL, MAN.
THERE AIN'T NO VACANCY, B!
>> KING KEEF DOES NOT ACCEPT
THAT!
BROUGHT THE WHOLE HOODLUMZ SQUAD
TO THIS TRACK!
>> HOODLUMZ!
>> WHERE YOU AT, L'IL NITWIT?
>> KEEP IT GREASY, Y'ALL.
>> WHAT HAPPENED THERE?
>> WITH 2 BLACK GUYS.
>> BAD NAME!
>> WOO!
>> AND HAWT CLOWN.
[ BLEEP ].
WHAT IT IS?
>> PREGNASTY!
>> NO!
>> AND Y'ALL DON'T FORGET BOUT
YA BOY SKIFFLE!
BOW-YA-YA-YA-YACK!
>> OH, SKIFFLE.
>> YO, DEFINITELY AIN'T NO ROOM
FOR SKIFFLE.
>> YO, SKIFFLE, SING!
♪♪♪
>> AND YOU KNOW KATY PERRY ON
THE TRACK.
>> WITH KATHLEEN BELL.
>> UH, MAYBE NOT KATHLEEN BELL.
♪♪♪
♪ HERE WE GO
NEW MUSIC ♪
>> WITH ESSENTIALLY SIMON,
MODERN DAY WITCH.
BRINING THOSE MUSING LIKE:
"NOTHING'S MORE DANGEROUS THAN A
GENIUS WITH MONEY.
>> WHATEVER.
ANYBODY ELSE?
♪♪♪
>> DAVID S. PUMPKINS!
>> NO!
>> YES.
>> ALL RIGHT, EVERYBODY COULD
STAY, YOU KNOW, LET'S JUST KEEP
IT ORDERLY.
ALL RIGHT.
FIND A PLACE TO POP IN, ALL
RIGHT?
HERE WE GO --
♪ BIG CHRIS ON THE MIC ♪
[ RAPPING OVER EACH OTHER ]
>> STOP!
STOP!
THAT DID NOT WORK.
IT'S LIKE I SAID, THERE'S TOO
MANY PEOPLE ON THIS TRACK.
I'M SORRY, Y'ALL.
>> DAT SNATCH OUT!
PEACE!
>> WHO THIS?
>> ANY QUESTIONS?
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]